Of course, there are certain problems that a computer can't solve.
It can't appreciate the beauty of a painting for example.
A computer cannot predict the outcome of a soccer match at least not accurately
and of course, a computer also cannot see into the future
and tell you the lottery numbers of next Saturday.
So, at this point, we have to start off a little bit more formal
and specify exactly what kind of problems we are talking about
and what we mean when we say we want a computer to solve a problem for us
And we will do this through three requirements.
These requirements might seem very obvious to you but later on this unit you will see
that these requirements actually has some very, very important consequences
So, the laws of computer problems.
Rule number one for a computer problem, the input must be given to us
as a finite string using a constant number of symbols at each position in the string.
The input for a computer problem could for example be a number of zeros and ones
It's not infinite so it has a defined end
and by constant number of symbols, I mean, constant number of symbols at each place
So, in this case, at each place in the string, we either have a zero or one.
Here, we could have a zero or one. Here we could have a zero or one and so on.
You could also have a string like this. Again, its finite in length.
And this time, we're using the real alphabet.
So, it doesn't really matter what kind of symbols you use as long as the number is constant
and that is basically the same requirement that we already have when we discussed the RAM.
Because for the RAM, we also said that at each memory cell,
we could only have a finite number of symbols so no variable can be arbitrarily large
and the same thing as here, we cannot use an arbitrarily large alphabet at each point of the string,
Rule number two is exactly the same as rule number one with one exception
instead of input, we write output.
So, we also want the output to be given as a finite string using a constant number of symbols.
Actually, we could ever restrict ourselves to decision problems here,
but we're going to keep it general.
So, you get the computer a string and you expect it to out put a string
and then finally rule number three.
Is that going to be as surprising as rule number one and rule number two?
Yes, it is. Because rule number three is going to be that if we get an output
then we want that output to be a correct answer to our problem
and that is one important point and answer where we can objectively say that it is correct
The moment that is given to us and it is suppose to be definitive
So, we do not want the computer to say
Oh let me work on this for a little bit longer.
When it produces the output that is suppose to be the answer.